la verità è che vorrei fare un video
serio ogni tanto ma non so non sono
capace pelle a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video io sono sono
dei capelli che non si possono guardare
ma fa niente
oggi signori volevo parlargliene
argomenti un po particolare perché mi
tocca in prima persona no allora
partiamo da questo presupposto se avete
aperto questo video perché vi siete
lasciati e quindi state cercando del
conforto io proverò a darvi questo
conforto perché vi parlo di questo
argomento mi sono lasciato l'altro ieri
mi vedete che sto bene 9 quindi questo è
un mostro questo non ha sentimenti non è
così non sto proprio benissimo sto già
meglio dell'altro giorno ma diciamo che
io mi vivo le mie situazioni in modo
molto particolare allora io quando mi
lascio con una persona se con quella
persona aveva un legame fortissimo e mi
è successo due volte su tre io mi vivo
la separazione da quella persona come la
morte di un parente stretto e non sto
scherzando cioè semi morisse un parente
stretto
io proverei penso lo penso lo stesso più
di così è veramente difficile perché io
quando mi lascio non mangio non mi alzo
la mattina e non voglio fare niente non
riesco a lavorare non riusciva a
studiare i tempi non riuscivo a fare una
mazza e quindi sono stato male quindi la
prima cosa che mi viene in mente quando
vi lasciate che quando vi confrontate
con i vostri amici
esce fuori il discorso nella vostra
testa soltanto la vostra testa
sì però loro non riescono ma non
riusciranno mai a capire veramente che
cosa prova quindi inutile che mi dicano
poi ti passerà perché loro non sanno
veramente quanto ero legato a questa
persona è vero fai bene a fare questo
ragionamento perché nessuno può sapere
che cosa tu hai provato la tua redazione
ma ti assicuro che non c'è chi farà
strano ma ognuno quando si lascia si
sente speciale si sente come nessuno ha
approvato il mio dolore
io lo sto provando ma nessuno ha provato
un dolore così forte ti sbagli se stavi
insieme a una persona e non ne puoi fare
a meno
oggi ti trovi in questa situazione qua
sappi che c'è gente che ci è passata e
ti assicuro che il tempo cura tutte le
ferite questo è il periodo in cui non
riuscite a guardare niente che vi
ricordi quella persona non riuscite a
guardare
deluxe e vi siete regalati non riuscite
a guardare le foto non riuscite a
guardare un film che avete visto con
quella persona perché poi viene in mente
a caso l'ultima volta che l'ho visto
l'ho visto con lei barra lui e che state
male per qualsiasi cosa
oddio anche lei vedeva l'acqua naturale
anch'io è normalissimo tutte le persone
che hanno amato davvero passano questo
questa esatta sensazione chi più chi
meno ma una cosa è certa il tempo
guarisce tutto questo è sicuro nella
prima relazione ho amato tanto
tantissimo quando mi sono lasciato non
volevo fare niente della mia vita perché
non aveva niente senso qual è la mia
paura più grande in quel periodo me lo
ricordo la paura più grande era quella
di pensare di non riuscire a trovare
un'altra persona in grado di darmi le
stesse emozioni che mi dava la mia ex
ragazza
quindi io ero lì della serie maino
troverò mai una persona così ma mi stavo
sbagliando e non potevo saperlo perché
perché avevo solo quella relazione avevo
provato solo quella relazione quindi non
avevo metodi di paragone ogni amore
ragazzi è diverso voi non potete mai
trovare una persona come quella con cui
siete stati quindi non potete mai
rimpiazzare una persona con un'altra
pretendendo che li faccia provare le
stesse cose perché vi farà provare delle
cose diverse ma allo stesso tempo forti
la mia ultima relazione mi ha fatto
provare cose molto diverse dalla mia
prima ma di eguale potenza 15 sono stato
male allo stesso modo in partenza con
una differenza molto grande e quando mi
sono lasciato la prima volta io stavo
così male perché di opel ha detto che
avevo paura di non riuscire a trovare
un'altra persona che mi facessi
innamorare così tanto invece poi è
successo con la relazione che finita
poco fate mio animo sa che potrà ri
succedere cosa che invece non sapevo la
prima volta fortunatamente oggi so che
non è così ed è per questo che mi vedete
così anche se mi sono lasciato l'altro
ieri e quindi non posso dire che sto
bene perché non sto bene ma so sono
consapevole vista la maturità delle
relazioni che ho raggiunto che un giorno
proverò la stessa cosa se non anche di
più magari e magari non si creeranno
questi problemi si siano creati questa
volta quindi le relazioni stanno nel
maturare ragazzi ognuno da una relazione
deve imparare dai propri errori e
migliorare nella prossima tutti e due
tutti tutte e due le persone che che
hanno vissuto la relazione se vi siete
lasciati state male ed è giusto è giusto
perché un percorso ma io vi assicuro che
passa il tempo guarisce tutto questo è
il garantito
ora per concludere cosa posso dirvi è
visto non fate commenti del tipo così
tranquillo che ti riprenderai ragazzi io
sto veramente a posto
non sto facendo questo video per
vittimismo anzi giuro su dio lo sto
facendo solo perché mi trovo in questa
situazione ha detto cavolo
io ho raggiunto questo livello di
comprensione delle relazioni e magari ci
sono persone che non hanno ancora
sviluppato così tanto quindi non vi
posso alleviare il dolore ma posso darvi
una mano
è per questo che voglio provarci perché
so che fa male ora nel mio caso la
relazione che ho avuto
nel mio caso specifico c'erano tanti
fattori che mi avrebbero dovuto far
capire prima che non era la relazione
giusta perché tante cose non andavano
però ero molto affezionato e quindi
quando tu stai con una persona ma la
qualità della relazione non è al top
questo non vuol dire perché magari con
la persona vi siete veramente
affezionati quindi il cervello ti dice
forse non dovreste stare insieme ma il
cuore di dice sì provaci
e io ci ho provato fino all'ultimo poi
però non è andata e qui che mi frega che
frega tutti noi in realtà perché il
cuore pensa una cosa al cervello ne
penso nata cioè ve lo dice scappa il
cuore ti dice rimane però al cor non si
comanda lo dicono un po tutti lo dice
anche gigi d'alessio questo
questo cosa scusa comporta comporta che
nel momento in cui ti lasci stai da cani
giorno dopo giorno dopo giorno passa una
settimana ne passano 2 passa un po di
tempo
ognuno ci mette il suo tempo ad
assimilare inizia a calare quello che
era l'affetto perché non vi sentite più
tutti i giorni e quindi rimane solo
quella che era la qualità della
relazione e se la qualità della
relazione non era il massimo
allora 1 dopo un po dice vabbè ma sai
che c'è meglio così sticazzi però sul
momento state male di brutto cercate di
stare vicino magari a delle persone che
conoscete che hanno subito questa cosa o
se avete subito voi stessi cercate di
stare vicino ai vostri amici
cercate quando avete una relazione anche
futura di non o se ne avete uno adesso è
stato bene insieme
non chiudetevi con quella persona e
basta cercate sempre di avere le vostre
compagne e di uscire fate sempre in modo
di avere persone intorno amici e
famigliari e non rimanete da soli io ho
voluto condividere questa cosa perché
secondo me era giusto per un video del
genere visto che tanti voi ci passano ci
passeranno ci sono passati anche la
relazione più bella anche se state con
johnny depp che johnny depp di molla
anche lì è risolvibile
state tranquilli spera vino ragazzi vi
sia piaciuto io continuo a fare le mie
cose con la depressione non scherzano
molto orgoglioso di meco anche questo è
un altro punto è poi un giorno quando
migliore lette su questa cosa magari
avrete un altra delusione d'amore perché
ci sta non me lo auguro ma ci sta a me è
successo sarete orgogliosi di voi stessi
di quanto siete maturati da quel punto
di vista magari con una relazione che
gli ha fatto provare anche di più di
quella per cui state soffrendo adesso e
voi capirete di essere maturi perché non
state più male come prima non perché non
avete amato ma perché sapete che è
risolvibile lasciate un bel mi piace e
schiaccia della campanella perché sennò
mi metto con vostra sorella bacio